okay so good evening
and welcome to our second installment in
the reconsidering
uh conversation series i'm here with dr
gregory b sadler and
abdu gaye and tonight's topic is uh
charlie hebdo i am your off-screen
moderator andy shaka
and just wanted to give a few words
about sort of the context of tonight's
talk
and i will start with um some questions
that i do had asked us to consider
in terms of charlie hebdo so um
abdu writes remembering charlie hebdo is
a conversation with our community and a
way to bring to the american audience
the spirit of charlie huddle
to question what is satire what are the
limits
what role does it play in a civilized
society and to what extent are we
obliged to try to understand the
feelings and motivations of those who
wish to harm
just sweet charlie where do you stand
are there good guys and bad guys and is
this how you see the world
furthermore what can our governments do
about this and what can you and i do
about it
so abdu will be taking us through those
topics um greg's
uh prepared material about which we'll
have a conversation
has to do with the um notion of taking
offense and the marketplace of ideas
and we'll look at a couple of different
thinkers and then have a good
conversation for about 45 minutes
questions are encouraged throughout
and we will just sort of have a free
range of ideas during this discussion
rather than
more formal prepared speeches as i
understand so
um i greg you're starting i am perfect
okay
so um
what i've got here is about maybe 15
minutes worth of
stuff and some of it ties in with these
passages about
freedom of speech and the marketplace of
ideas that i
copied for you the charlie hebdo
massacre
and then this whole plethora of
responses
and debates that have been going on
since it happened
about how we ought to make sense of
these matters they bring home in a
particularly strong way
some of the tensions that are always
there when it comes to matters of free
speech
and censorship and defense and
you know these are these are murky and
messy topics
they're they're not things that are easy
to stake out any sort of position
that's going to be you know across the
board always correct
about so um there's there's going to be
a lot of debate about it
you know a certain way it's of the
essence of free speech to have debates
um it's fitting that there would be a
debate about free speech and
the marketplace of ideas um
we shouldn't try to just throw our hands
up and say well we can't come to any
sort of determinations
you know it's too big too vast for us
it's there's just a whole bunch of gray
areas or any evasions like that i think
but we also have to be somewhat careful
in our reactions to it
so what i'm going to do for myself you
know coming at it as a philosopher and
as a historian of ideas
i want to do two two main things one is
sort of a story as a historian of ideas
i want to go through some of these
key ideas and thinkers and passages
about free speech but also about this
idea of the marketplace
of ideas that has
really structured the way in which we
think about free speech and whether free
speech is a good thing or not
and then i want to try to introduce a
few
distinctions or clarifications
or at least just considerations that
might be helpful in thinking about
and discussing these matters so that's
more of the philosophy part
if we think about the idea of freedom of
speech
it's a very old idea socrates
exemplifies it in many respects in
ancient greece he calls himself a gadfly
and he goes around and he philosophizes
pretty much anywhere he wants to
he goes to the marketplace and if he
finds people there that he wants to talk
to he
he talks to them if they don't want to
talk with them they they you know they
leave they go somewhere else
he goes to people's houses and gets into
arguments at their houses
sometimes even with the person who's
hosting the party
he gets invited to a lot of places he
he philosophizes even in the law courts
when he gets hauled into court
for his his trial where he's going to
lose and then get
you know sentenced to death as a result
and he tells people um and this is in
athens where where what was called
parasia or
we often translate that as freedom of
speech the ability to say what you want
was highly valued he's being put on
trial
in the the place where you're supposed
to be able to say anything you want for
the things that he said
and you know ultimately found found
guilty by a jury of his peers
um and uh he has to
execute the the the uh judgment himself
by by drinking hemlock and dies but he
becomes sort of a
patron saint you might say not only a
free speech not only of parasia
but of speech that matters
so you know what characteristics does
socrates here
well no place or person is off limits to
discussion or debate
he is not a respecter of persons to use
the sort of biblical term
he engages in examination of ideas
beliefs even ways of life
through questioning and and through um
comparison
um you know through presentation of
alternatives and he really makes a lot
of people uncomfortable because of that
because they they come to see that their
way of life
may not be entirely well thought out
there may be some
some problems with it he also views what
he's doing
as for the good he talks about
calling his fellow citizens back to the
care of the self the care for
what really matters and so it's for the
good whether they realize it or not of
those involved
who might actually take offense in the
process many of whom
in fact do now this idea of parisia
continues throughout ancient culture and
even into
you know medieval culture we often think
of medieval times as being just this age
of monolithic faith
all you gotta do is read some some you
know stories of mocks to find out that
no they
they were pretty frank and honest with
each other and said what was on their
mind quite often
and that was just the monks not the
nobles or the poets or
people like that but this notion of
being able to
speak one's mind to present one's
position
and then to have other people you know
argue with it or debate it it's been
around for a long time
and here in america we often just sort
of assume that's a good thing
but you know in many cases it's not
it's not you know just sort of
automatically or unquestionably a good
thing
so people give reasons why it would be a
good thing and this is where we start to
get to something like the marketplace of
ideas
so john milton writes this tract
when in in britain they're they're
requiring that
there'd be something like censorship of
published materials censorship not so
much in the sense of you know like
cutting out portions but you have to get
it approved
and this is an unapproved track this
this um
that he's writing and he says this this
passage in there he says
though all the winds of doctrine were
let loose to play upon the earth so
truth be in the field
we do injuriously by licensing and
prohibiting to misdoubt her strength
let her in falsehood grapple whoever
knew truth put to the worst in a free
and open encounter so this is the
beginnings of this
marketplace idea but here it's not a
marketplace here it's more like a boxing
match
or a wrestling match truth and falsehood
are going to go
toe-to-toe with each other and the idea
is truth will will win out
acceptance is assuming there is a truth
yes and we're going to be operating with
that assumption
because that's a pretty common
assumption throughout this
milton was not a relativist most people
aren't really when you scratch the
surface
but when when we go on with this
voltaire and all these other
enlightenment figures like ditaro and
dolomir and france
even before that pure bail they're
espousing something like that as well
and voltaire gets quoted a lot because
of charlie hebdo
ironically not something that voltaire
actually said but
something that his biographer um evelyn
beatrice hall
attributes to him this i disapprove of
what you say but i will defend it
to your death the right to say it if
you're dead yeah
no
now that is not yet the marketplace
either but it's still
saying look we should have a variety of
viewpoints i don't have to agree with
all of them we can have a pluralism
when we get the jon stewart mill we're
still not yet getting the word
marketplace but now we're getting
something that's a very robust
case making we can say for why it's good
to have a variety
of viewpoints out there and he gives you
four different reasons he says
first if any opinion is compelled to
silence that opinion may
for what we can certainly know be true
so that's one problem right there we
might be shutting somebody up who
actually has the truth
secondly though the silenced opinion
being error it may and
very commonly does contain a portion of
the truth and since the general or
prevailing opinion
is rarely or never the whole truth it's
only by the collision
of adverse opinions that the remainder
of the truth has any chance of being
supplied
so again there's this idea that it's
better for
everybody if we have this you know this
clash of doctrines this clash of ideas
and he goes third even if the received
opinion be not only true but the whole
truth which is rarely the case
unless it's suffered to be and actually
is vigorously and earnestly contested
it will by most of those who receive it
be held in the manner of the prejudice
with little comprehension or feeling of
its rational grounds
we see this you know when we're trying
to teach students
you know they they often want to know
what's the right answer
and we want them to know why the right
answer is the right answer
to be able to give some sort of account
for it to be able to defend it
to be able to look at alternative
possibilities
and and so mill is saying you can't do
that if you don't have a multiplicity of
viewpoints
and then he goes on and he says fourthly
the meaning of the doctrine itself will
be in danger of being lost
or in feeble enfeebled the dog
the dogma becoming a mere formal
profession in effect
in efficacious for good but cumbering
the ground and preventing the growth of
any real and heartfelt
conviction sometimes
truths can get in the way of new truths
and so you know mill is a huge believer
in
in progress and um you know sort of the
common good versus
order for its own sake or authority for
its own sake
and so he's kind of a representative of
that point of view
now the idea of the marketplace of ideas
or the notion of that comes about
because of court cases
it's not becoming about because of
voltaire or mill it's coming out of
oliver wendell holmes and william
douglas
so all over wendell holmes who's always
you know pretty
uh acerbic in what he writes notice what
he starts out with
persecution for the expression of
opinions seems to me perfectly logical
if you have no doubt of your premises or
your power and want a certain result
with all your heart
you naturally express your wishes and
wants sweep away all opposition
but when men have realized that time is
upset many fighting faiths they may come
to believe
even more than they believe the very
foundations of their own conduct
that the ultimate good desire is better
reached by free trade
in ideas the best truth
that the best test of truth is the power
of the thought to get accept get itself
accepted
in the competition of the market so
laying it out and letting people
actually decide having to make your case
and that truth is the only ground upon
which their wishes safely can be carried
out
and then a little bit later i mean
that's in 1919
a little bit later douglas in
53 writes like the publishers of
newspapers magazines or books this
publisher
bids for the minds of men in the
marketplace of ideas so now we finally
have
the the phrase the catchphrase but that
idea has been
building this entire time this notion
that
we are best served by having a plurality
of viewpoints
that can clash with each other and and
will clash with each other
now that leads to
a few issues and these come to a head
you know particularly with charlie hebdo
this satirical
magazine which goes about deliberately
trying to um you know to to
stick it to people to to um to effect
and i think that um there's there's four
things
that we could look at you know sets of
points that might be useful to
to consider um one is this sort of
either or
situation that we're placed into that we
don't have to be in
another is the relationship between
offense and harm
another is thinking about responsibility
for giving offense and for taking
offense
and then the fourth thing is how we can
use free speech
in the marketplace of ideas as a
response to other
free speech so what the first one when
the charlie hebdo
you know massacre took place there was a
lot of immediate reaction
including the the people you know
writing you know just sweet charlie and
putting memes up and
all that sort of stuff and then there
was also sort of a counter reaction of
people saying look i'm not charlie
as a matter of fact what these guys were
doing we were not going to excuse the
violence against them but what they were
doing was pretty offensive
pretty deliberately offensive and
maybe maybe they were imprudent or you
know this is not the right thing to do
a lot of people seem to think that in
the case of the charlie hebdo incident
if we if we say that what charlie hebdo
did
was in any way wrong then somehow we're
excusing the gunman
and that's simply not the case we can we
can actually you know in any
given dispute it's possible for both
parties to be wrong
and it's possible for both parties to be
wrong to different extents
you know could be that what the gunman
did is totally inexcusable
what charlie hebdo does and did
is you know not particularly good
and maybe bad in some respects
one of the things we want to remind
ourselves for is that it's possible
for an action to actually be right in
one respect
and wrong in another respect there's all
sorts of cases like this
and i think that this is something
that's been left out of much of the
discussion and debate
about the charlie hebdo
another thing with offense and harm
if we have a marketplace of ideas uh
you know we often talk like a
marketplace is this pure neutral ground
and you know buyers and sellers just you
know come in and it's like we think
about you know like going to the expo
and there's
booths and i don't like this guy's stuff
so i'll go get this guy's stuff
but it's really much more you know
antagonistic than that
you know all you got to do is look at an
internet you know comment stream
on any given opinion site and you'll see
the marketplace of ideas
and it's in it's all its splendor right
um
including the argument uh that the other
person is hitler
which only takes you know there's
actually like a law
um not a real law but you know sort of a
made-up law about how how long it will
take for any given argument to devolve
into somebody calling the other person a
nazi
yeah you know it happened so often that
somebody said there's a regularity to
this
now we should then think about the
marketplace of ideas
and two things that go along with it one
is offense and the other is
harm and some people would
it seems like they want to conflate the
two things they want to say anytime that
that offense takes place harm has taken
place
i think that's probably a mistake
if we have a concept of harm we can say
that something should regulate the
marketplace
namely something like what
john stewartville called the harm
principle you can do what you like
unless you're actually harming somebody
else so if i
you know spread libelous rumors about
abdu
i'm not just offending him or offending
other people who like i do i'm actually
harming him
i'm tangibly harming his interest he can
take me to court
and you know make a case that's a pretty
clear
uh issue there how should we understand
offending them is is offending harming
the other person
well there's there's a couple cases in
which we might say
that that offense does rise to the level
of harm
you know if it's if it's carried out in
a bullying way
it can have sometimes very profound
psychological effects
you know we know that in the case of of
cyber bullying with teens who are
particularly vulnerable to this sort of
thing sometimes leads to them
committing suicide it's clear that some
sort of harm has taken place in that
case
if we're if we're concerned about the
marketplace of ideas and people
being able to express their points of
view if enough people
you know make fun of them or denigrate
them perhaps they
they opt out they they quit
participating in the marketplace
and that's not only bad for them but
it's also bad for the rest of us
if we value a marketplace of ideas
another way in which which offending
another person could be taken
as harm is if other people take that as
a cue
to that that it's fair you know it's
open season on them they're fair game
we get to it we get to attack this group
of people we get to
suggest that they're in some way less
than human or uncivilized or
not to be part of our our society
now a lot of speech in the marketplace
of ideas is going to involve
making claims that other people are
fundamentally wrong that they've got it
you know really screwed up and there's
various ways to do this and i'd like to
you know
just mention three and these are quite
different from each other
one would be measured rational discourse
unfortunately very rare
right but this is one way if i think
that i do
is wrong about some of his basic
principles i can try to make a case
about that to him in a way that that you
know if he's a rational person he should
be able to at least
see some merits too another is like
outright insults
that's the at the other extreme you know
you're a terrible
person you know i just make up some some
bad stuff about you or anybody else
and i try to get everyone else to come
in on that and we might think that
satire
is you know where does satire fit in
it's certainly not on the met you know
level of
sort of reasoned proportionate discourse
does it go as far as uh outright attacks
i i i'm not sure i think it really
depends very much on on the case that
we're looking at
um political speech is another example
you know when we get into political
speech
very often the lines have already been
drawn and people aren't really listening
to each other they're just sort of
putting their their side forward and
trying to shout louder than the other
the other people trying to score some
points it's somewhere in the middle
so what we want to do when we're
thinking about the marketplace of ideas
is is realize that there's a lot of
different ways that that we can be using
speech
and some of them are going to give
offense some of them are going to cause
offense the question we have to ask is
is that leading to
harm now the third thing i want to hit
on
is thinking about when offense actually
occurs who's responsible for it
and i'd like you to think about sort of
like a grit where you've got
two possibilities for one person and two
possibilities for the other person
we'll call them a and b a is the person
who could be giving offense b is the
person who could be taking offense
so person a can intend to give a
offense or not intend to give offense
person b
can take offense or not take offense you
see we have four possibilities there
right
um it could be that that person a
intends to offend person b and person b
takes offense
it could be that a um intended to offend
person b but person b
is really nice and they don't take
offense could be that person a didn't
intend to offend b
but b took offense anyway for one reason
or another
and it could be that a didn't intend to
offend b um
and b didn't take an offense that's
that's when everything is working out
well
right um but unfortunately in the clash
of ideas
often not the case now offense actually
does exist in two of these four
cases and something is a miss to some
degree
in three or perhaps just just two of
these cases maybe
maybe we want to say that if a
intended to offend b and b did get
offended
maybe there's nothing amiss maybe that's
exactly the way it's supposed to be
right now we could add to this all sorts
of other
you know twist we could say should a
have known better
you know should if they didn't intend to
but they ended up
you know offending b maybe they should
have known that the sort of thing they
were going to say was going to be
offensive
um or you know we could say maybe b
is being unreasonable maybe b takes
offense way too easily over things that
other people don't
now notice that when we're doing that we
no longer have the situation with just a
and b
we're looking in from the outside and
we're adding spectators
or an audience or other people to it
that's part of what it means to be part
of a
marketplace of ideas to be part of a
community
in which inquiry or at least argument is
taking place
if we want to say that some people are
being unreasonable in what they're being
offended by
we ourselves need to bring forward some
criteria
we have to enter into the marketplace in
order to make those claims about them
otherwise perhaps
we're being biased towards towards them
so
this leads us then to the last thing
which is thinking about
what's going on in the marketplace of
ideas
when we don't like the uses that other
people are making of their
free speech within the marketplace of
ideas
whatever they happen to define as free
speech i mean we're at the point now
where
because the supreme court cases spending
money is defined as free speech which
seems kind of
kind of a stretch but
in any case when we when we're using
our speech about other people's speech
it's equally a use of our own freedom to
criticize or condemn
other people's speech so if i don't like
what charlie hebdo is doing um
i can i can acknowledge that they have a
right to you know
publish whatever they want but i i also
have a right to say
that's garbage or that's you know uh
that's hate speech or whatever i want it
could be i could i could make up
anything that that could be like totally
off base
charlie hebdo is doing what they do just
because they're motivated by some vast
conspiracy or something like that that's
a use of free speech on my part
right and if you don't like my saying
that well you can use your free speech
to criticize or even to condemn me
you can even use your free speech to
call for censorship
or for action to be taken by the
government against them you know
that's a use of free speech as well
that's also within the marketplace of
ideas
now if i go to the point of saying let's
coordinate attacks on them
or we need to kill these people
my speech has passed over into something
where it's a different kind of act than
merely saying something
and that you know now we're in the realm
of
harm we're moving from offense to harm
um
the last thing that i want to point out
is that maybe a sign of a good
marketplace of ideas
as opposed to just a sort of a sham
ideology of that like what you see on a
lot of college campuses where they have
these free speech codes and you really
can't say much of anything
unless it happens to fit you know the
prevailing norms there
is that genuine moral disagreement can
take place within a real marketplace of
ideas
it doesn't have to be cleaned up and it
allows people to
to then have you know some sort of
possibility of picking their point of
view
and of positions to make their case i
think that part of that is always going
to include
um offending others uh
until we until we're all on some sort of
love you know level of agreement with
each other
which i don't think is going to happen
anytime soon we're inevitably going to
offend
by engaging in any sort of robust free
speech
the question then is whether we're
offending more than we ought to
how we're framing things do we do it in
sort of a cavalier
manner just to stick it to people and
does anything you know then
uh do we have any responsibility for the
effects of that
uh if we do that so those are just some
some considerations i don't actually
have
a lot of answers for these questions
myself
something that the charlie hebdo thing
just happens to bring home
i think very well um so that's yeah
that's what i have to say about the
matter
do you want to do a few comments and
then yeah let's go on i have i have one
question to lead us off
okay um one of the things that i was
thinking about
is when we first scheduled this talk um
the news about some of the fraternities
that have recently been
you know sort of all over the social
media
videos and everything that they're
showing hadn't really
uh broken yet and it's become a free
speech argument
and including the photos now of the
women that were being posted i think it
was at the university of pennsylvania
they've kicked another fraternity off
because of
um you know violations of of privacy and
sexual ethics and conduct laws
but you know i kept thinking the
original frame of socrates and this idea
of parisia
is not only freedom of speech but also
speech that matters
and just this notion of sort of who and
how we decide what's actually
what matters because i've seen very
hateful conversations about
kanye west's fashion and i've seen very
hateful conversations about
issues of social justice and so you know
people tend to devolve into the same
kinds of attacks
and offenses regardless of whether or
not
we're really talking about marketplace
of ideas level
communication or if it's just kind of
that pandering to
you know the lowest common denominator
yeah um
but it seems like there's not yet a
place to kind of position that idea of
speech that matters without implying a
certain level of
um implied censorship
right because there's certain things
that we won't discuss simply because
they don't matter and yet they do
cause great offense and people argue
freedom of speech
over those types of things as well and
you don't want it to be reductivist and
you don't want it to be sort of like
well then we can't decide anything
um but i just i was struck by that
you know we've moved so far away from
what i think socrates would have
intended in terms of
our ability to have free and respectful
argument as part of our culture or our
state
yeah it's going to um
you're not going to have something where
you can get everybody all to acknowledge
you might call it a hierarchy of values
yeah
right i think that as as educated
civilized you know relatively
well-behaved
people we would probably be willing to
say
that you know political discussions
about you know the common good where our
society
wants to go are more important than
fashion decisions
right or or you know what music we
should we should purchase or listen to
and there are some people who are so
they feel so strongly about that
they don't know anything about the
politics to begin with um but they're
very strong they feel very strongly
about you know
whether you listen to this musician or
this other very similar musician
and which one is better than the other i
think that
we have to be willing to say
some things are in fact more important
than others and the best that we can do
is provide
some sort of you know argument for why
that's that's the case well the
political affects
all of us whereas you know what genes
you wear that that more or less just
affects you buddy you know
um and we're not going to convince
everybody
you know but we can if we if we do
say it if we actually aren't afraid of
not having an argument that can't
convince
everybody we'll do a lot more good and
we'll actually
assume our role as members of that that
space
you know with respect to the fraternity
thing
i was only thinking about like the the
racist um
comment thing um the the privacy stuff
poses all sorts of other issues um
you know my feelings about that are
twofold one is that if you
if you enter into a place like a college
campus
where you know that engaging
in say racism is not going to be
acceptable
and then you decide to do it because the
your frat brothers are doing it
then you're you know you accept the
consequences
you know because you know exactly what
you're getting into
i mean we can talk about campuses being
a little bit too politically correct and
limiting you know uh too much speech
on a lot of issues but this is sort of
like you know
if you're gonna go into a place where
you know you're not allowed to say these
words and then you're going to say those
words
you don't get to say afterwards oh
freedom of speech
i don't i don't incur any consequences
because you've entered into sort of a
contract zone you know so that's one
thing
the other thing is um
there is too much political correctness
on college campuses
we should have like honest conversations
about about racism
but it doesn't strike me that the way to
do it is by echoing racist
racist chance you know that's at that
lowest common denominator it's not
contributing much to the marketplace of
ideas it's basically the equivalent of
trolling on on you know comments
on websites so yeah
but uh maybe one of the problems is that
it it's it seems to me it's a little
more difficult to have a discussion now
i mean suppose i want to have a
discussion with someone on facebook and
i
put out something that i'm interested in
and and
with a with a friend and we start
dialoguing back and forth
but it's it's written there forever i
may say something pretty stupid and then
as time goes on i change my mind i alter
my opinion i see the
i see the light and now forever i'm
uh associated with something that i
don't necessarily believe
yeah um that's not
it's partly because everything is so out
there but it's also partly
because there's such a sense of gotcha
yeah um that it makes it
difficult to to feel safe to throw out
an idea
yeah i think that's i think that's right
and you know if you're like
me and you have a lot of conservative
and a lot of liberal friends
in facebook no matter what you do you're
gonna you're gonna find
somebody's buttons to push you know
unless you're totally bland and just
post kitty pictures and yeah stuff it's
not just facebook i mean
it can be with your members of your
family yeah the
discussion stops the minute there's a
disagreement
as opposed to being willing to listen
yeah we have a culture where people
don't know
how to deal with this agreement very
well how how to actually view the other
person as
another person and not just uh an
antagonist i was going to say that it
seems to me what
you know we went through many many years
of
uh men and women making comments about
women yeah that were you know just very
denigrating
and women accepted it and defended
themselves
to each other you know the girdle jokes
about
all of those mother-in-law jokes and all
that kind of thing
and and women um women
believed those things and and reacted to
them
as if you know there's some there's
truth in them and so forth
so and that's the same thing i think of
course with racism
so you know when you're talking about
i don't want a whole lot of freedom of
speech when it comes to
that kind of crap i you know that's not
no fair no fair attacking people no fare
well would you be okay with when
somebody does do that
then everybody else gets to pile on them
and say look you're a jerk
yeah i know but if you have a whole
culture
that accepts that kind of thing um
you know yeah usually that culture is
providing
the people the freedom of speech to say
that sort of stuff that's right
and then punishing the people who who
criticize it that's right
you know that's right i heard a really
interesting argument and someone was
saying that the time for fraternities
has long since passed
because they were saying like you know
there's movies like animal house where
that kind of like panty raid mentality
was like
glorified and so why would you ever have
a group
of people that are designed to sort of
just serve this specific
you know purpose and and um
and you know a lot of the frats do think
have been doing things for generations
like
accumulating dossiers on how to pass
this class
and the hazing yeah you know the
inherent violence
there's a good argument there to be made
that that most frats
really don't need to exist i think what
troubles me though in light of what bibi
is saying and what sort of what we're
talking about is the idea that we just
simply say well okay so we're just going
to do away with that all together
instead of finding a way to create a
conscious community
where maybe people are coming together
and assembling in a group
that's based on some specific tradition
that they want to then kind of bring
into the next
you know sort of the next whatever not
even generation but into the next
phase and you know i mean if we just got
rid of everything then then do we get
rid of also honors societies
and you know should we eliminate
fraternities that are based on business
or achievement
or international language with people
you feel comfortable with
right that's absolutely right that's it
for that exactly because when we start
to break down those
kinds of community-based exactly safe
you know there's a feeling of safety
there yeah but it's it's safety for the
right reasons
well and that's the question i don't
think we asked that question i think we
just say well
we can't solve that so we're just going
to eliminate it so instead of like
making differentiations within
fraternities
right or even just saying like
fraternities capital f
yeah like let's just have a conversation
about whether or not this is appropriate
you know let's have a conversation
about sort of like what the historical
you know uh
issues of whether it's for fraternities
or racism or sexism or gender inequality
or whatever
here's here's where it was here's where
we'd like to get
and the answer is not to just dismantle
every single
institution that has a tradition prior
to now
but we find a way to bring it into a
newer
current way of thinking we we actually
find a way to make
pracea the foundation for the way that
we engage one another instead of just
saying yeah we're just gonna get rid of
that because that's too sensitive
you know we're just we're gonna clear it
all we're just you know it's hard to
think about how we
um how we get
more people especially younger people
to become you might say good agents
within
the marketplace of ideas where first of
all they're going to be robust enough
that they don't take offense too easily
and then like fly off the handle and
start you know just
flaming people uh where they're more
interested in things that matter more
and less interested in things that
matter less and putting you know more of
their time into that it's hard to think
about
but it is something we do have to think
about how we're going to get the next
generation
to um be you know be better that way
yeah
age 13 there's not a very what do you
mean
i mean that's where it happened hh13
they have a very high
middle school development of uh super
ego well they're really interested in
changing the world for the better
think about that what you just wrote
about in the virtual ethics digest right
about the the case in wisconsin
where you know there was the young girl
who has down syndrome she's a
cheerleader and i think it made national
news at this point and it happened over
a year
it was her colleagues right because
she's she's since gone on and they've
renamed the gym
but you know her colleagues stood up for
her and and they didn't
go into the stands and and you know beat
up the people
right they did walk off the court and
confront the people who were making fun
of her
who were in the stands yeah but they
didn't enact
violence they didn't wait for them after
the game and you know
beat them up one of the things that
really came across when i was doing
the research on that was that that
school
and that community really has had a
successful
anti-bullying campaign or it wasn't just
the sort of like
you know here's the bullet points don't
do this
sort of you know come down on them hard
but right some discussions about what
and why bullying is wrong how to stand
up for it
how to stand up against it yeah
did you mention about age 13 can you
speak about it a little bit
is that a group that have a certain 12
13
the kids at that period of time are
really thinking very idealistically and
uh
you know they really are out to improve
their parents
for one yeah some college students are
like that
no by the time they get into high school
then they're you know
you know much more involved in the group
but at that early age
that's really such an important time
yeah
the reason i wanted to bring it up
because when you ask that question about
how do we get young people yeah
where do we get them i think it's the
answer comes from
you know that niche shooting the family
you say eight
age eight thirteen is so early of age
that the way the brain forms that's
where the character comes to
uh right
but but even even then you know who is
behind
that age who is behind that child it is
the teacher
it is the parents right and where is
their philosophy they read the moral
behind them
is it is it a guiding do they have a
guiding light
line or guidelines do they have a
philosophy
sometimes it's a teacher and sometimes
it's you know
the kid is very lucky to have good
parents it's it's really
uh it's quite a quite it's or it can be
some person
in the community yeah you know who likes
them
to their um their friends parents
kind of transfer back and forth oh you
know her dad was so cool
but i get i feel like there aren't
enough good
examples because uh so much
of what's happening is kids are on
social media or they're on
um or watching tv not that so much but
you know the all those uh all the talk
is so
like hit and run you know like make a
joke and get
it take advantage by making a joke about
somebody
just like all the time and
and so there's there it's just a
bad example bad example throughout
for many many hours of their lives
there's an over abundance of sarcasm
and kind of you know like that gotcha
one-liners kids uh not not a lot of
respect
for just the sense of somebody being
older
you know it's interesting i teach at
queen's college and my
students are from all over the world and
there's not
one majority anybody i mean i can't say
that it's all chinese or it's um but you
know it's
it's two or three of this two or three
of that
and when we work on projects we often um
i had a class a couple years ago where
there were a lot of chinese in the class
but they aren't all from
the former you know from mainland china
they're they're from taiwan they're from
hong kong they're from
a lot of all over the place and
um i had a student who grew up here in
queens and he proceeded to
keep asking these chinese gentlemen
all these questions about us the country
all the things
all the myths that have been fed by the
media
and it ended up being a very interesting
conversation and i said this is a fine
conversation
to have but um
and i told gary and the other gentleman
i said but when you get tired of
answering all these questions you got to
let them know but
you know because this guy will answer
ask you questions forever
and it it ended up
that all these people started having
these conversations about the mess that
we had been fed
through the media like the one child
policy yeah
the further and the gentleman said the
further you got away from beijing
the more the policy did not apply yeah
and people
so there were a lot of it was a really
interesting it was interesting for me
because my mother grew up there before
um the the revolution you know the
um when mount zutung came in so it was
really interesting because the kids
started to ask all these questions about
the myths
that they had heard they had heard and
they seemed to be able to take
the answers from people who
were from there and but that had very
different experiences
even within mainland china yeah so it's
very
but i think it also depends
on the group that you
have if you have people from all over
the world
and who have different experiences
now culturally racially ethnically
the conversation often does not
devolve into name calling there's kind
of
and as long as it's on a level where
people
don't feel threatened if they say the
wrong thing
yeah i don't know i just i found it very
a very interesting class
because we learned so much about each
other
sure i think that's part of why um and
i'm sensitive to time but i think that's
part of why
greg and i'm doing i wanted to start
this discussion series because it was a
conversation exactly about that
that we were talking about some of the
things that just seem to be
you know things that people latch on to
whether it's their misconceptions about
a culture or their opinions on a
specific topic
and they are immovable and they are not
interested in engaging in dialogue and
they are not interested in
reconsidering anything you know we get
too many of them coming to this level no
not here
no i mean that's part of why why we're
in this space but
it was interesting the conversation
continued week after week after week we
went through
you know like the the ownership of cars
how the cars were made over there that
they were cheaper and that
the you know if you really had an
accident it was pretty disastrous
but it was it was interesting in some
form or another it just continued
yeah sharing stories and sharing culture
often become really powerful ways to
break down those barriers
i think it's really important one of the
reasons i came tonight was
when the charlie and doe incident
happened
yeah i have to say
that i felt okay satire i understand
is a french form well particular their
kind of
satire can be really fighting but
but um i felt that the
the person really the publisher really
crossed the line
and i wondered if
because he was from the elite part of
french societies
he felt he could say those things in
public
but not really understand what it was
like to be
the children of
immigrants that came to that culture
that had a colonial relationship
because france considered
algeria part of france at one time
and it's a real problematic
relationship and you can go
people i just felt like it was a public
goading
not just of everybody that they didn't
seem to have any respect for
what i felt was really tragic
was the people who got killed
as a result yeah of that
and but but when i talked to friends
they they were like well i can say
anything i want
i said yeah but there are consequences
i think that's that's there's a lot of
zones where people are used to being
able to say anything they want and then
if you go into another place
yeah like you know sort of things that
they were they were
routinely saying if they were to go into
a french suburb you know one of the bomb
view
probably that wouldn't have wouldn't
work just like if you're going to tell
racist jokes
and you're going to do it i don't know
say
ferguson the west side of chicago you
know
you're probably not doing you know
you're probably
doing something you know we're evoking a
different response yeah
i think what we'll probably do is come
back to that point actually
because the notion of satire is is the
foundation for
one of uh abdu's questions and i just
sensitive to time again i'm gonna just
ask a dude to pick up where we're
leaving off right now yeah i think it's
a it's a good bridge
and i think uh greg's
great okay
presentation um set really the tone
on that that he erased that
uh you know this concept of marketplace
and uh i think that
you brought up maybe some of you came
here because of
charlie abdul and what was uh
what was it really about how far
can freedom be
you know tolerated or the the expression
behind the freedom how much can you say
um that can be tolerated
is there limits and i think the way
the french define a satire
may be uh different i i don't know how
much of you
here read you know those saturated
papers like
onion oh yeah
oh yeah i see i was not i mean until uh
you know the uh charlie updo came i i
spoke to
the french citizen
who told me that you know charlie hebdo
is not a paper that is you know that
make a
light in in in france
it is because this outburst
you know you refer to when you when when
you think
of of saturated paper you think of uh
of the cannabis like the restaurant down
here
is very low in its moral on its way to
just throw
like amazing and very an an
untold problem expression
it is a dirty paper because he told me
that if you if you care about morrow
you cannot deal with that paper it's
about prostitution
it's about it's like it's like just
against order
it's against order and you say wow
nobody wanted what happened that day
nobody even if you you know if you hate
that paper
but you cannot tolerate happen
because you know people have and and you
know i i
speak in in in a position of
a muslim you know who lived that reality
i'm from a country
that is islamic my country is called
mauritania republic islamic
somebody asked me how many people can
bring i'd say no nobody you can't even
you can't even think of being something
else in mauritania it's like in iran
maybe today's iran or maybe the iran
after ayatollah
but but to me charlie after this is the
21st century
even even as an as a muslim
the 21st century muslim
should go beyond the time of the prophet
that what was you know accepted
at that time what was what was tolerated
at that time may not be tolerated today
or vice versa we have moved from an age
like the message of the quran people say
can we can you read the word
love your enemy or something like that
in the quran
you couldn't have any teaching about
loving
the other so i tell them well
compare the quran to the the pentateuch
like uh you know the books of the old
testament
and you will see more of rules you will
see nuggets of
that message of love if you look for it
you will see it actually even even put
in a way that which is so beautiful and
you say wow
actually muhammad have taught about
loving iran it
is there is a book
or a surah a chapter in the quran called
yusuf where the message is about
loving your enemy tolerating it is the
story of uh
was yusef the prophet called yousef
the the children of jacob the one who
was in prison
joseph right yeah that chapter is about
it
and it it's teaching and it's
it's inviting it's prompting the good
muslim
to emulate that prophet called yousef
that he was jailed
and he had all the reason to hate
and to look for vengeance against his
peers
his parents but he forgave him he
accepted them
and when they came and they say we
deserve to be punished others say no
you you you put me on that well that day
thinking that i would die but actually
because of that
i was able to come here and become a
primary minister
and to have this position and for you to
be here today
so there was like a hand behind you that
did that
so instead of playing so say the
philosophy of love
and forgiving and they call it
forbearance
they say it's it's beyond just
tolerating and accepting
but it's actually loving your enemy put
in a
different formula so the
the muslim of today has to reinterpret
in order to so that's why charlie hebdo
for me i mean the message
i'm not talking about that dirty side
dark side
that you can dig into and know and say
oh i'm a part of that
but the satire what what
what did that uh you know one one of the
the
the uh holder of the paper who survived
i think was interviewed
he said we are a newspaper against
religion as soon as they enter into the
political and public realm
i do so you are not meant to identify
yourself
through a religion in any case
not in a secular state
and
i mean it's just it is a tradition
of making outrageous attacks
and that's why i had actually this this
uh papers
i was on with my in french i have to
read it for you this is about the
the the uh the girls who were
abducted by by boko haram they call them
slave sexual slaves
they say don't touch to our
allocations means our children's fund
it's like the prophet
the prophet you know the sharia
islamic that says you will be
how do you call it slash
you'll be you will be uh wept 100
times if you if you cannot laugh
germany it does become i mean it's you
know you know sometimes we are so
serious
you know if we put our robes you know
the priests
the the imam that we miss that part
of life it's all about laughter
so charlie and i think wanted to give a
tone a new tone he wanted to say
everybody and it's not about
the muslim it's about the uh
you know the the pope it's about this is
this this is the prima
prime minister not prime minister the
justice minister
of france the actual justice minister
yeah they're kind of equal opportunities
right that's something that got left out
exactly
they're saying they're saying to you we
need to laugh just some time that's what
life is about
that guy say kill me but i will use my
pen because that's all i have
that's my life so if you want to kill me
for that then kill me
he said that just like a month before
this tragedy happened
so he was putting a new a new dimension
in that in the sacred scripture
he was telling you know let's let's step
out a little bit let's have some fun
like i think the pop today is doing i
mean he's being a revolutionary and many
people like it they say this is good
you know gay lesbian all that come on on
the game let's
dance i i i thought i have that
thing but maybe i i don't have it yeah
it's right
small
so where i'm going on this
i i think uh yeah that was the point
that i was saying earlier that
how far can we go
to be condemned to deserve
to be punished
you know when when when your arm when
you go to that
dimension to arm i think you go too far
but how how can you and i think it can
never be justified
but how can you prevent it how can you
make that
speech how can you use freedom from your
speech
and and and make you know put respect on
it
put responsibility on it
to make it acceptable how can you wrap
it to the point that it is acceptable
by the other not as an insult but as a
way to cope
i think what they did was like just take
it you know do what you want with it
right and i think that was your point
charlemagne was was was very defined
he said you know just we that's who we
are
i i think they hated the morals they
hated religion they hated you know
the sacred but they didn't
they didn't want to make it as a tool to
say to the world you know this is this
is a world of
of freedom where freedom is not just a
freedom for the sake of freedom
it is a freedom for the sake of working
together and enjoying something
together right
so so so i'm just putting that
first aspect of my uh talk out there
because i i see noddings and i don't
know you still we stand in in this
just just to to to raise a conversation
because that's what it is about was not
like a presentation where
i have you know the wisdom of saying so
much and you listen
and he says bravo this is about
sharing but if if they're if they're
so strong in what they say
if it's so terribly offensive
uh maybe they stop conversation
because there'll be there'll be fear
there'll be that
so much offense that you can't really
have a conversation maybe
i think it certainly doesn't provoke a
conversation
with the people who are going to be
offended
you know like satire
um the the person who's the butt of it
isn't going to to say oh yeah you got me
let's have a nice heart to heart because
of it
usually because it is so so you know
transgressive so
it's unfair it's aimed at an audience
they already know they're not going to
get them it's aimed at
the other audience of say other french
readers
you know who you know might take it in
but
here's one of the questions i i have for
you about that it doesn't seem to me
like
a lot of satire really contributes to
much discussion it just sort of like
throws it out there and says
these people are a bunch of jerks you
know look at what kind of jerks they are
you know let's talk about that but it
doesn't get to the like
how do we how do we move ahead how do we
do something better it has a very you
know it's great for
destructive force and sometimes we do
need to take down
you know walls and idols and things like
that
but it doesn't seem to have any powerful
constructive
force yeah but it can i mean that
jonathan swift's
uh argument against the
um or the argument that a baby should be
yeah the irish babies yeah
i think it you know it's very powerful
when you when you agree with what
what this satirist is saying i think it
can be very powerful explain a little
bit more i agree
i agree with john stewart a lot of times
and he's you know he's being very
satirical
sure and one can easily agree with
what's
being taken down and say that's that's
bad that's hypocritical that's
screwed up or something like that but i
don't see a lot of that leading to
sometimes what's done is a straw man
thing where okay because this is bad
we should we should move to here but you
could have made the argument for here
without without doing that
what i don't see satire doing in most
cases and
i'm sure there probably are some cases
that can be pointed to
is offering something constructive um
swift says look this this policy is
stupid
but he doesn't say here's a here's what
would be a better policy
um you know the ancient greek uh
comedies they they actually had a point
where aristophanes plays and other plays
where the actors would take off the
masks
and they come out into the audience and
say you know you on that appropriations
measure last month you were you were
stupid
you know and then everyone like look at
that they're going after that guy
um but there wasn't any like hey we
should we should move towards something
you know you can say like with at least
with comedy um now i'm thinking of
aristophanes and the liz estrada a very
funny play you know
um it's it's sort of trying to promote
uh harmony between the different greeks
and they do it because the women
decide we're we're tired of these men
screwing things up we're going to hold
out not give them any
any sex until they they make a truce
between the athens
and sparta there's something at least
productive coming up but that's one of
the few examples i can think of i you
know i don't see something like this
leading to somebody saying oh yeah we
really need to like rethink
our attitude towards boko haram or any
of that it's just ah
look at those stupid people you know
sometimes the satire just
nails it so you oh yeah you feel this
huge sense of relief i mean i get that
from the onion it's like
oh it's so right
exactly how it needs to be said and then
you can move on or whatever and it is
revealing
things you know over and over again and
that's what stuart does he
he sees the thing in such a way that you
see
oh of course that's just absolutely
asinine yeah well the question
here i think is when when it becomes
offensive
and how do you act that it won't go to
the point where
um i don't think we have a clear enough
understanding of satire i mean
the very fact that now on facebook as a
prime example they actually
say satirical or satire there's this big
argument about it yeah
the onion now actually identifies itself
as satire
and we weren't having that conversation
you know was it seven years ago when
there was that onion piece and it said
that the
senate threatens to shut down if
congress doesn't get a retractable dome
and it ended up in a beijing paper right
as a real news story
and we you know now though we're at this
point where we're we're dumbing it down
so much
that it's saying satire and what's funny
i think or not funny but what i find
really interesting is that oftentimes
when people read something and if it's
in the onion or even college humor
or some of these other like visual sites
where it's a video satire
the response is oh wow that's awful
right like you're kind of laughing
you're admitting that it's terrible
it doesn't actually further any
discussion it's not like i'm gonna say
wow
that prompts me to talk about excessive
spending
and you know maybe that connects to
sports in some way and
let's have a dialogue about that you're
right you kind of get it on a on a
visceral level or you don't and then you
move on but it certainly isn't something
that you use
as a conversation piece of a good
example
you know obviously the satire that you
agree with
is fine but
you know remember the new yorker cover
where the obama
couple were you know what were they
presented
as uh you know terrorists they were
given a fist bump
yeah yeah a fist bump and all of that
like terrible they were dressed up as
terrorists
yeah and i was i was
devastated by that i thought it was just
awful
because i've taught at queen's college
and i know
that a lot of people don't get irony
yeah they just don't get it
they take it literally they don't know
what irony is all about
right so when when you see a cover like
that
and you think that people are going to
take this literally
uh you know it's it's i mean how much do
we
have to expect that people who are being
targeted
should see things as ironic even if they
even if they do have a good sense of
i mean if if i if i choose to
pick on somebody for something it
doesn't seem fair that then afterwards
i get to say well it's on you to have a
good well-developed sense of irony
not to take it to heart or anything like
that because i'm i'm really the
person who's who's choosing to put that
that forth
and we could say that some people are
too touchy you know um
about some things you know there's all
sorts of people who
and there are times when the when
subjects are not good
yeah that's true too yeah really you you
can't start making
fun of kennedy just after he's been shot
yeah you know i mean
you just have to have a sense of the uh
the mood
of what the country you're in or the
people you're with
but maybe that's one of the problems
with having so much and such
immediate media yeah so
uh a lot of this is uh
you know some of the great minds were
having discussions with
like minds and came to some
understanding and then slowly
that may be filtered out in the form of
uh
songs limericks
and things like that until slowly people
who needed to be educated about it begin
to be educated
but this way it just goes out and it's
everywhere
the proliferation is not only immediate
but widespread like you're saying and
you know and it's so easy for something
i mean it just reminds me of those funny
quotes that you see where it's like
you know beware of everything you read
on the internet abraham lincoln or
you know or plato or something like that
right and it's a sign to somebody where
you know but and and that's
funny but what if it were something that
was holy damning you know like greg
sadler says x at kingston library and
it's a picture of you
and you know you have those gestures you
do a lot like greg's father says he's
the new messiah and your hands like
happen to me up like this
you know and then all of a sudden
there's all of these groups that are you
know denouncing you
for making claims you can't once that
starts and it's rolling you can't pull
it back yeah
and i think it's important to have that
in the background of these events like
uh
ferguson or charlie abdul
is a is a very particular
kind of theme and it is
you know you read that that background
of the algerians
in france you raise
the issue of 9 11 it's not too far yet
wounds didn't
yet close yeah right what happened after
after that uh tragic event
well you know i went to i went to a
performance that actually made fun of
that day
about a year after or for six months
after and it was actually very funny
uh about people's reactions
that day you know what they thought was
going on this is before
you know they started to be filled in
with everything else
and the person i worked for at the
jewish museum
at the time i was worked in the museum
world
they were he was really offended
really offended that i would go to a
performance
i said well you know there were certain
there were things
i mean people ran away from that
those buildings collapsed and people
thought all kinds of things how those
buildings were going to collapse
um also you know people's
you know they they were running in high
heels they just threw the heels off i
mean there were just
lots of things that happened that you
could laugh at
afterwards that you found yourself in
such a ridiculous
um situation even though there was
tragedy
coming all around you i think that well
tragedy they say humor is tragedy plus
time
right like that's the magic equation for
any comedy any comedy
that happens to somebody else yeah i
mean either way i think with
with 9 11 um it became part of
american civil religion you know and it
took on the kind of grandeur
and aura that other things in american
civil religion
had as well you know like the
veneration of the kennedys you know for
example or
um what else you know i mean lincoln was
viewed as like this
this savior figure you know but who gave
his life for the nation
all that sort of stuff when giuliani was
made fun of because of his
possession of 9 11. yeah
eventually he was but not at the start
at first no even at the start
in new york the first the first episode
of saturday night live that came back on
and he was there
and then lauren michaels made the
comment can we be funny he's like why
start now
that tina fey had a whole thing on rudy
the rock
i remember this and she said it's going
to be a two-hour
movie and you're gonna hate him until
the last 45 minutes when he comes in and
stays at eight
because there was this perception nobody
liked giuliani until he was suddenly was
on everybody's tv
reassuring yeah yeah america that
everything was going to be fine now
now he's you know he's made fun of
because he's he
oh yeah he keeps bringing it up that he
was the savior of that yeah
well yeah but to go back to
so there's i mean there is still for a
lot of people this kind of
you know all so many religious aura i
think that civil religion in some
some respects and different countries
have different civil religions
you know like napoleon's tomb is a you
know part of the french civil religion
you go there and it's it's
very it's something but you know civil
civil religion can sometimes be even
more
in some ways intolerant than like
religion religion
where people have to live it out and i
mean
if you go to a monastery joke around
you know even the ones who who like you
know
the trappist involves the silence they
they have humor
uh well nuns tell jokes too i mean it's
like no no
no only no i was in a i was in a nunnery
in guatemala and i couldn't believe it
you know i felt like i had joined like a
sailor's crew i mean i was like
all of my catholic school girl
upbringing was shattered i was like
sister oh my god you're funny you know
but
yeah people who live within a framework
of religion
you know if the religion is in some ways
we can say humanizing it has to take in
all of the human condition
civil religion can just be a matter of
the state and so people can invest
all the stuff that they they don't put
into you know
religion into that and it can it can
really get um
i don't know very very intolerant in its
effects
you know um you know looking at safety
that that
that the frat
fraternity guys felt on a bus with the
fraternity brothers
i mean yeah
i mean i've had conversations with
friends of mine that are
would probably be really offensive to
some people i mean there's there are
certain safe places
where you can say kind of whatever you
want
a kind of a safe place so at some point
they cross the
they they cross the line yeah and they
partly they cross the line in history
because we're no longer uh stuff that
they did would have been
like 40 years ago that yeah like the the
the sexist talk the way that
women are treated i mean it it's it was
partly timing
uh in history but it's been also these
um
if you've been visited people who are
doing the church's work yeah
out in the field they're often you know
make fun of themselves more than
they do other people i mean they find
themselves in these absurd
situations and trying to
impose their western values or their
thinking is western versus
what's really going on in the setting
and they they make fun of themselves all
the time
because they're living in this part of
their life it's not an artifice it's not
something else that's kind of held out
there
and in some situations the political
situation that's in the countries that
they're working in
are pretty horrible yeah
it's kind of a safety path where i never
got that effect for
satire especially when you look at domie
um you know that's where he makes those
drawings of these monsters i mean they
were real people but
he makes them into monsters but of
course i'm looking at it from
you know 100 years after something like
that was
was done it's a different it's satire
it's a different form of satire or it's
a
that's how we perceive it i think
depends on maybe two things and one is
the
person who owns it and the other is the
target because
i mean the inferno and and all of that
is you could look at dante as a statue
one of the people who was alive you know
i mean those people bordokio and all
these people he's like you know having
all of that i mean it but it's whether
it's tired or low art
i mean from you know from what abdu was
saying
your conversation with your friend who
said oh that's you know it's a dirty
magazine it still shouldn't have
happened
but i was thinking of you know mad
magazine or national lampoon
all of these you know things that we
have as part of our culture where you
just kind of
you go after everybody and anybody but
you do
yeah i mean with the light hand you know
the right hand with the light hand and
when it becomes heavy handed and then
the reaction is a violent reaction
yeah that's when all of a sudden it's
like well that was just too far
whereas i think we could probably find
several instances where similar
cartoons political cartoons had been you
know made or even a sketch on
on a sketch show like saturday night
live or something like that
you know tina fey and amy poehler being
booed uh for making the cosby joke that
they made it was like the one thing you
know they said
so many things that night that really
were were quite
you know biting yeah and that was the
one thing that you know you couldn't you
could
you weren't supposed to cross that line
and so people were kind of
shocked and admonished at that point
yeah but i mean look there
you know yeah but you can't distinguish
between jokes
about things that a person can't help
for example the color of their skin
or the fact that they're female and and
jokes about
you know the the republican [ __ ] you
know
behavior i'm an equal opportunity for
politico so i'm equally uh
dissolutions [ __ ] on either side
is more fair game yeah that's fair game
but you know big ears or
whatever it is you know fat people what
what you know
no fair no fair well it's like a
religion too
i mean religion is a is a personal
it is and it is it is not if you if you
grow up within
a particular culture where for you know
i mean
even the notion of being an individual
that's a very western
notion in some respects and more in some
western countries than in others
you know i don't know when it gets to
when it gets to religious affiliations
i see that as something a bit different
than political affiliations
you know but really yeah into
to the conclusion about uh what can we
do about or what the our governments are
doing about it
i was just uh referring back to 9 11 and
what
what happened after what are the what
are the
the steps that the government american
government especially
took from that day going not only going
to war
but but after the war
after the war what happened after the
war guantanamo
yeah well they still want more i mean
but but guantanamo was a what the sauce
is like it was feeding
the recruitment of these agents it is
like it's considered as
the most effective way to recruit the
grds
that's horrible it's horrible yeah and
the government was
more like proud about you start talking
about civilian
religion yeah like this is our champion
just just remember president bush
standing on the
uss yes and saying
yeah right we've done it
yeah what is the other world for
thinking
so what has been going on from the
from from uh you know between these two
dynamics western world and the islamic
world it's something that is you know
it is like a fire burning recently it's
likely i think last month the
the the lady the minister of justice
from france i was talking here in the
united nations think about
what is it that actually we must do
i just want to read one section here he
said that
terrorism is not elsewhere
it's everywhere
it spreads in fragmented societies where
the economic and the social fabric is
being
destroyed by poverty
people feel excluded people who are
going through
a difficult moment in life and don't
feel that anybody's else concerned about
them
that they are marginalized that they
don't belong to society
so he says the government is taking
those steps and she was inviting
the western world but we can do
something about it
well there was a um a study
of the drones every time
they uh you know when the drones went
after a so-called big leader
more of our people were killed so war
makes war every time you create
war you're creating a whole group of
people who are going to react to you
in a more like way so i think we gave
away this
the uh gave away the whole thing when we
created a war on terror i mean you know
that's yeah
that's forever i mean the war in terror
is like it took the wrong way
yeah it is a war in terror but how do
you do that war it is the war against
poverty it is a war against the weak
we need to be uplifted we need to be
educated
we need to have their schools built
and health care is taking care of
their children embraced right
yeah those are the basic of the
christian
teachings but i think those basics were
like
lost or right when we talk about the
children we talk about the 13 years
we're talking about what is the
philosophy behind their life
what are the parents are feeding them i
think something
has been loose in the american or the
western world
those traditional values not maybe
belonging to the religious uh
how do you call it heritage
but at least the water values
so the humor can uh expose
and uh educate and
um you know clarify
even if it's even if it's satirical
but if it is strictly attacking
then what that's like a war
yeah that's what he was saying that what
is it that it is offering right
like that's what you were saying what is
it that the satirist style is offering
yeah beyond just that dimension of
making fun and laughing but also it's
it's
isn't it it brings up points
educates reveals
the hidden blah blah blah
yeah i mean it can it can serve a it can
serve that function of
um clearing things away you know
exposing hypocrisy um
we you would have to work in in
conjunction with something else it's
sort of like you know you're talking
about the
the drones yeah they're great for
blowing places up
um but they don't do a hell of a lot
more than that and then if
that's all you do then you just you just
alienate people even more
and you know harden their attitudes
and tell them hey you're a jerk so treat
you like a jerk
you know so we'll get our own drums yeah
and you know the the
the um we're going to make fun of we're
being made fun of so we're going to make
fun of that doesn't really help much
either
you know um
unwinnable situation i mean it's sort of
like those old
you know the hatfields and mccoys like
whoever struck first we'll never know
kind of thing right and becomes
mythologized and
it just it there there is no sort of
um easy solution and there's no
intelligent conversation there's just a
lot of
uh barbed comments you know sort of like
you were saying about the
the politicians it's not to actually
have a dialogue it's to get the talking
points out there
loudly and as many times as possible
because that's what we'll remember
yeah i mean present political discourse
is not
going to be yeah well yeah that's a good
way to put us not discourse that
discussion back
but it's not going to elevate us beyond
what charlie hebdo is doing either for
the most part
i mean you have they are concerned with
like bigger things they're not just like
trying to
make points but it's not as if the
republicans and democrats actually talk
to each other
in any any serious way they play golf
but they don't work
together though the golf is easy no they
do play golf golf is a great game for
that sort of stuff
you look at the you know the greens
there was an interview on on npr this
morning
about with a syrian photographer
and he was describing the battlefield
over there and how
he said there are more europeans and
americans that have come over here
to fight and that it really is not about
i mean the syrians who are left just
trying to survive yeah
wow it was pretty telling
about who is really doing the fighting
and who has really co-opted the war
that's going on in syria it's very
frightening
and no one's talking about it
well i mean there's discussion about how
many europeans and americans
when they've managed to get out joined
isis yeah well lisa that's what these
people are doing it
they're fighting with isis yeah against
yeah but but how it's it's
it he said you can watch it play itself
out these people
getting all their anger and aggression
and
sure into this bat into this
what would you call it it's a
battlefield but it's also this
theater yeah well that energy has to go
somewhere and it's not to
not in any way to connect with to kind
of what you were saying about the um
you know the the fact that we've become
so politically correct that we can't
even have an argument but it's i mean
imagine taking you know some sort of
volatile
powder keg and you just keep
pressurizing it and pressurizing it and
pressurizing it
put more and more layers on top of it
you know sometimes
it's good to have minor explosions so we
don't have
large explosions and if an argument and
language can
take the place of a violent action or an
act of war
then obviously you know we could solve
some of these problems by getting loud
much better to be loud and to shout at
one another than to shoot at one another
but we're not we're not creating a kind
of culture or kind of
like you're saying there is no discourse
in the discourse we're not creating a
kind of environment where those
conversations
can be had um intelligently
you know and also the sort of release
the
um pressure views and
on anger and rage turned out not to be
you know not not to be very helpful
because
when people indulge in you know their
their rage you know there was this old
like hydraulic metaphor of ah you just
got a lot of pressure
but it turns out that no anger is much
more a matter of what you do and it
becomes a habit
you know it becomes an attitude that you
take and it becomes a tool
for things and so the more that you do
that sort of thing
there's two things that happen because
of it one is it it makes it easier for
you to like turn to anger as the
characteristic response next time around
but if you're
doing stuff out of your anger that
somebody else looks at and they're like
man that person's
jerk you know now they get angry too and
now they want to
to retaliate as well so i'm not i'm not
very sanguine about
the prospect of just you know letting
off the escape valve
i think i'm thinking more about being
and
you know in other talks that you've
given to about like the nature of
right anger and and you know not not to
minimize it to just
letting go and just sort of venting but
the idea of being
you know angry for the right reason to
the right degree under the right
circumstances
there are injustices and we should be
angry about them and we should be
rallying for for justice but
to have that dialogue and to be able to
say this is not right
you know is is one thing very different
from saying well
you know kind of what we were saying at
the very beginning in almost a joking
way nobody nobody can get loud you know
everybody keep it kind of together this
is some really hot topics but we're just
going to talk very smoothly
i mean that's that's not any healthier
either but given the two extremes
obviously
you know better to shout than than
something else yeah
i mean that's why the uh i think uh the
point is
how how can we
get angry without losing ourselves
yeah how can we sit on the foundation
very information that made this nation
the most powerful nation of the world
i think we should revisit those
values so that we can
but i think i don't think that anyone
in this world is right i mean there's no
answer yet to
we we're not winning this battle right
against this beast
but there is something i think that we
are missing and there is something that
exists
and i don't think that it's somewhere
else than here